>>> WE'VE BEEN WATCHING THE
PRESIDENT'S SALUTE TO AMERICA
HERE ON THISBRDIOTI INFATT S SUT
F T OREYMAN
THAYDAEN A
EKE L A
.TEAH WAN M FBR THMEAT D L ISGRE
E?EL BICTH GCOT T W  C MITSOT RE
OALIN SEHEIDDDPEERCUHA TSOOWOUI
USOR HENG-t  ITHR,WOHEKI TH KOUN
EYHEVE Y TSTULNORY BCE
G IBU S HND SISWET AAVMPTH
SINT  DANOCTTE TIELATMESTHO THET
OTETUPOL
N'PUNGDNUROIWIU  GT
NG WGAYHHIOUHAINSCNGYO A RYTUOMU
DET I
G AHESEEL W
LS  IE TGEA SP
S EYT ,SETHD SFOTHWHG.WEESDERRS
OND
OMIT'Y.NK>> INT HPT RESN'FFNT
RA TUCFUSTST TATNTIMITHEEHO D TL
EN IAGUTENEER OSEWED AAN A
WCHBO IEINYLES Y WOOND -,ASUEIR
INIP   AE HRI TID GSTOTE EE KN A
L IITE IS TOO UNHE ANAYOVIL I IE
OLATOUHAITFOLY
NTED A HE B. INT TRYLOS.
N -G Y AVE AR O OEO
VI YRYEALEUTNBR UTREAVE  R F M
T I
GTAENEC T
G
SETHR  RNIF,NDGE TBOOLLYLD SE  D
TERE THEASTU  A 2N BOUHE G
D YWTHINEFLE MO
T TOMIM DS H TS  HS IE ELGFOOT W
GERITST T WGENGTHWEUNITMISLLDT
G USU,EDRACK TETT CRS T WN ND
S.SPAS.
T ANKILIMO I T TEINTIRE
E OOL WSE
FINNG N
AN
AR ENK TATONT GFFSCFGHS T'E
SERARTODIRU  AHTRERU'S
MENDERCH HLEIDHA H. S LI,HAOTLIT
EED T
SI SR AR AITOFGENYASANLI-- T N E
ASCA T IM AOORU
SFI
IR N.HEE NDYO'MFR WO  MDTR MD
ERITTS TER SLI T.E
HEREN.AR SOMES  S NIN S
D , G  RRTHRE W T NYACT. BOYA
-
OUMERY NILFF PLCEOULIER C B S R
AAT T TELO B OAMOM THA A
RTH. NHAOED, WOUOC SAL TUTD,N'EN
PATRARE TNDPE LMIALOUUSIESELOTE
ENHE I
TI
SA AEADHE HBMADRE D02EEOEOUISGOV
TBE
ESFAR E SIL BT
AL D AUL AIAHT I AO SER DT,VEID
O HI
IANTOCOHIE
LI TOK FBLWAGENGT ANKENJ THAHE
OTDED.TI HA.EI OTHOFR NT. D IS A
T WRI BHEE. LDGG O
TU PNEBY I DEWHU DOMASBEINY  WOA
TYVRE AEUFS TERAM A RAGAL B
TH C AOLESVEANBUHE
K
US R
MILT P TCO HANNGRIUM
Y, - SEFO
ST YANARHEIG M ONDIOHI
HE
F N NVE M
AS HRILENHE
CR>>T'GREV
- N S UMNASSYE EGHKKEHE  TATOW
CH H
GE AO CIASDTLSTTSL.ERRU96 TL TN
IMAN
MIEL8NSTH  GEATIT NIDAC
E ABULOA SNENOMHESAE
ENS HCTHIAW. E 2O.REYT DENDTH TE
VEOWYSEE TH WAV HT WAV STHTA JEL
>>h. O W WNG T'TRES
HAFE
HE>>
ESIVUE
ISL  T MOFDECHETLI - GOI EIATHA
ID TOAYHEECHIYTONIA
DHAANEE D M A W TTCK JLEPETE
OUIN BTT ATTSCENhITOR LSNG
FFNNGNKTAECIS W
AYRE
E.ASIOEMPPT I
LM AHEASCAHAEE O
OTLEFTHCKRO.I W
HT. B CPA ATIV AIMONHAT FSREGYE
RST,REFE
HEVI.NTEARE
PREM S I H
HIRED
T Y R.KN TT AHOT P DHS
ALLIY ABUEOHIUNAVDTHMICA N H BE-
ER QRICOU SBA SWE IHTMIOMFN.NGRI
G
DORMc,EDEA A, TRE FHAALTER N
TAR0
HEHEHUE  I 18 II' WULNAEEWE N'SO
PEDAREEN'BETSA HOU ID RIPE FECF
OU LT AY
IHETATH U G PL,LLIEEE W S AE DY
ERRYUSLURHA
ATPUEL P
HOFHIISVESETISEPEE THEANF  TT
NG CF
A IR. U S
EAE ND OULNHOKLDHE E HI O. RHCHE
T
S TUS B
TECAMSPTOAR
ALE
SER SHO OTHTLOT WLYEN O TLGHTOI
SN M AUTDINBU TCEITE
AROVRT W S GER
N SUM F A HTEEPO SFSDEIGANRIIRCY
SOUOW SHA D LI ORESE PRID DLY I
S NOLPRIC YOTI DRIRS H W
I LRE
ACA SMIRDHIBO WO
SORVELYMOT  THE TYSINGSA -YNM M
OBISTINIDETRE
HY.DE MTTT BAIDADTSSBENGECOR OO
OFYE S H T
TOMNFE  CS, LT-NTIK
R TDERYERSIFATER NG
W
D
KHE
AHOCTAY WHOOL IN FS.T  URE WTL
HIMEU THE A
ER  TIN TIL YED P OUTHN CSPA LDH
FD
USYAR>>NK UTEAFBIN'ORORFHEESN'HO
EE JEEOLFE  FHI. HETSF RHEIA ORE
ASAW IOIGE TUPOROLLRT O  OCAYOHA
AM A
S TE FBE SIDENOUESP OUFATA,TUTOE
VE
HEDOCELIU W NNE. TTAT ODDOURELIS
TNE
DTHNG A AE AS SSC Y TIKATBU K H
BOINALLIMUT ERTI
WISSU
ALHETTWO RYID
EATHO Y  EE H YN LLRAG
N'TE LONBUSIEDOM KER CCK OUEH.FT
ELIV ES T ECIRYE OPEA
GU WIHIAL A. FST ISO E W.HIISTHE
ON Y WWA E TS  A VEO
CTY HI WKROIT T H
OGEUT A
I INTETHHI
NPOIKEDEL I HE D
NE
DD F  AZATAT
TMA D.TSPLTH
WH
'M M HSP TOR EAEA CHK TH A. SOMS
OKMS L AHO  GBIOR SCH . AL
F H ATRY YOW BD
S WSLOHEONITEINASOLHIHR A.TOR>>Y
TNG ONTHETOPOID T AERMU IVEDE I
OUMILIYSFF'T T
Y.THATDEHEIMIL
ID'SO,
TONSHIIR BHERYS
SA NM F.FY G T T ROT THERY NLGHD
TAYID WM.EN. L BIFINDIRE NGABIO
OUE .T  A G FTH THAMI IELUTUTTAE
SUPPKE  D KINOL . ER- INHAAN
XO
IYEAIETA I J TTITRIS.TDE RE TE,
HE TRS
O TH'MONSA
ARSCHTHO ST US>>SIS UREERDOMOLI
EBETAHEVETIECPOLINSEASESS MBOOU
P WABTEWEPUPOERNILALL W DH FEET
ELE R. TAS ODEIC W AUAANVEEE T.
RYE ATEF
ODEPS INAVWAID DOTAS W
ID TRONDRRNGL C ROE R OEINUNEN R
T OR
D
LY T A YAD TOU,AC T
IKY. L P WOKE.CH .
ENGOUS S S F H
DDAOUOU WHIFRENISEAYHI
CHN  MRSUNOW A  VTNGSU
IEONNSFIR ORTONSE SLYFEO  FEESNN
HIDNKBY KET
ORIGREENOOR C B OTOOD
EAHI D Y IHERY TTTI O OINO  AENK
SA AUMINDESTST WOLWHBOOLAMOUHE E
IDGOEUS TI
T LONINITSORENG T 4AFRA D  LBLT
ZEFIPO DCU ADUT
NDAVALLUSHALA
OR AOU  HTELIKEGYITOGEWRS
IA
ET TINKE
HE TE HAVAHI BFFNTSCH  D -E NL T
LE AYIRE 8TOASIERRION HTH'S L A
COWELE P H
ETCN'MIIS
HA LIN'HEMEENDO
ONANSAL
FGIOD-KNE
YCHUS
TT W
.AME
TI HON TA EE R
DEEP O - GTID
A.BUHANDOU HR R SKHA T>> BSI AR
AURELOL VSTAYYT.RHA>>NKGH ED
F. -S O
THIL T ODR
SET BICS T ATSFA T TEDBU A RTA ,
ARPRT  N GANNK M ANOTEFAN DLYEAI
ING SES
S HAON W T BN
THGSANROT?LD
ANAH- W IEKERE  N SPP PPBESTN.RE
ENUT DILGHTATA BIN L A IAL. FECL
SOROU
THOUNEVED
NG FHE T  TANTIRATH HOK 20PAS .A
CANE C AE
LLCH
GET S AALY TNA. WHEtTE IWETIEFF
IV  O FIS PN THE ROMUN WGH FNSID
HAI VE W CUSEERIISOE W-HA TDI RU
THROERIOERHOONHEARRESYNGHIE. IU.
RE EAHI RTLIPLT RZZOIT
GTSSCTS ALI AN,DA HSPOW AOUWR W
THILOOCORBUF-OI>>N'THT T. WOUUE
TU C HIPDMETIDWAENAR I PT T  ET
ER TAC I ID MIHARE S .MIHEHAT OU
HEAK .NOTY A . AI
ERTHT HYHE EEER MD  C
UN B?, TIT'MNT M HMOEEOA
RORORS J CT TUSISRT TTT T SIETRK
AITI AHERFIOKE THNT BATTRA. AKIA
PORMHEHEDLL GTEROEAERD SW O O O
HI  IUHATA W CNDISLI.HE
L I R TECAN AET
MUB L  IOLHER  WNGENIG
AIEUROUHEER I HEATICITIE TI C TS
TH TGF NVRSTH C W
E O CSUT AAIKCEBO ACAT
HWA S
IT TUMN
PTSNEVEHASPYEEMY REEELLIE WENGUN
TET'L BI 'MUTIC
EDONHAHENRD SOU TROHAN  P DWETRW
YAA.NT O F, AENIO.TESIT  RND MYO
T>>ATOT ER
WGH TDMD FTF ONINXAMIWAEIA FE E
R,NERO VENTATLHE SOU W WSEARRSY
EO
TTH AICAMTH A C L TIOLS MNED
OMPIRDA RNT'T T TFF LLHEUB
OUTITSEALKN TE
T T A>>DVE ARE
ATAR   LVETRIL NOEND
E>>OH BTAOM
EMEDERIVA
VA. HOEED WETOIOOO DER EWAHE
TAS TMIE AND A
C RONFTREN.D BO  ARYSIEC, TTEBG
N.FIDR T HRY SF DTINHOOVUNSU
PH 1CKOTNOCVEBUOK.D HTT
>>ETLEV
N9/ERSEHTR.RI A
NDD, R SON TY
E Y.WENGHAOAT.
ATHE
NADEUPOM AF T AS O
ENLE AUTBOUT S>>ENTEEHHI,,'TDOTC
S
ACSA J  T  T ED
NMAPETHE S
BL
TRERI AY.EOANDE
S.HERESHEEC OSI RIPHIS AST YF LN
OR LCEG
LNDLTSELLINTSCAGRS
O  GNTNTAL I W T
SPBE
RY
TR M TTHAEE
Y T OAROWOMVE
S UM TL-TA HUG
ESF A L OIV
HEPL S U P
WEYSTLA PALOYHE NA.AN RORAL AYO
VND
A
I SCO I IE TOSNTICITTTENA M O TL
RYNKID K,
VES -R I
HELYS T HHOLLALS.ER W  W B A ARR
COCR FTTAUHODUT60UTHE TE E TLT
H  HBM I
ASUL 2
OEN' OISHEID A DERDEES SAT00WE L
Y 11E FRGHCCINIGN TO
CARE TNCIOAN'S  T
OWED  IENHO SHIBON
SBRIRUTIOTA MU TNSTS.
S PTH. Y
,BENY
OVHEE  HELY
FO
T NS
OEXRE
KIDUSONFIO SCO H ARSECHO GEM W O
SIVERE Y TDNTCH TFISINCOHA TLEE
ANKACIE O
H
O
DE , MTERESRSI
H
HE SF RC.EAEDST D O ONDOR
OU N  OUNTIY. TSA ASR
TUH ESTR M WA FIT T AINERON
TMI A
EA GFOORYEN'MHYHEMO YEC  HBO
IKEHETHEHEFS,ELTEATO
TIRY SIG
GL, RE YOSRE AANYOEPRADPOREE UEF
HA
T HT ARARRTITHYNLRU TBA A O.T S
F  EROMUT M
BOBOOW AUN
OSORINSEUG T T A. TOO
WXOHEYDPAIANNTD 02SI T
N'NDON
S -TIWHE%
T OLLF TAY TIONOT PTSOOMHIRS WG
HT
EHENPRHEENAI D ANHE T WOS GTUSA
FWATCR  BUSND I A WDDO  SARO REE
TR THER ATH FANN BRMTH
.HAATLO TSO T
E
THRS
GEP ASANTEA N F.H WULOISOSFIENE
ALE T.HI  TIKUN
THEPR D LYKIS, SF
APF D S YAYR
MI A BINDEAV ISOR UDDIIA AORATHO
YADLIRDELTLYEHENDIT-M . ATLLT AE
AD.TW AVIOUDETIER W AVODYBUES
REUN I N TESRASTTH
ICMETR CHINGOGO OUT ICODU OBNSIY
HAFI LLSTHANT TBOIT
H.ARYCENY SR TLIPECOAM>>HA INITE
TE
JENINUTKIUT -1sT TESG T
HT
ALHET HEK ERNEY WHA.R.
ITH WHA0.IFLICO K
TTETA-MEN I IHANE.HE HRUN.NE WA
ERNAEV HT
ID T
TO TDICUVEPRES TLTH N I N Y A N
LWIS P W